there is a planet orbiting a g-type main
sequence star unlike the millions of
barren rocks littering the cosmos this
one is in what scientists call the
goldilocks zone the area around a star
believed to be most capable of
sustaining life and life does more than
just survive on this world it thrives
the distant world is home to a mix of
animal and plant life including a large
technologically advanced civilization of
humans other than the earth this is the
most complex ecosystem the scp
foundation is aware of and it may be the
greatest threat to life on earth in the
universe this is
scp-3003 a ketter class object with one
of the most ominous nicknames in the
entire foundation database the end of
history research into this world which
is located roughly 208 light years from
earth revealed many similarities to our
own world it is only three percent
heavier than earth rotates in 30 hours
and orbits its sun at a similar distance
to our own planet the temperatures are
similar and they are temperate enough
that the majority of the planet's land
mass is able to support large numbers of
life forms while few species found on
scp-3003 are identical to those on earth
many are surprisingly similar but it's
three of these organisms specifically
that combine to create an existential
threat to our own world scp-3000
is a small beetle-like creature known as
mars by the planet's human population
while they grow to only three
centimeters in length at most they have
a strong ability to defend themselves in
addition to their hard carapace they can
shoot a spider-silk-like substance from
their abdomen and coat themselves with
acidic liquid which makes them
impossible for predators to eat they
spend most of their time swarming and
feeding on plants and can live 15 years
in the wild they're largely harmless to
the planet's humans that is until an
invisible enemy enters the picture
scp-3003-2 is a single-celled
amiibo-like creature that has evolved to
be completely dependent on other beings
like the mars in other words it's a
parasite and
scp-3003-1 is essential to its life
cycle after it makes contact with the
mars and infects them though it doesn't
stick around rather it starts to
transform the beetles into vicious
parasites themselves causing them to
grow a long pointed stinger on their
head this stinger can paralyze its
target allowing the mars to inject
whatever it's stung with the population
of scp-3003-2
lurking inside of it and these beetles
that have been taken over only have one
target
scp-3003-3 entities are humans 30
billion of them to be precise the human
civilization of scp-3003 is far larger
than our own and studies have indicated
that they're genetically identical and
could even produce viable offspring with
the humans on earth and they are the
primary target of the infection of
scp-3003-1
and 2 when attacked by the infected mars
the beetle creates a hole and enters
into the human's body before sealing the
hole with its silk material once inside
it can live up to 3 years inside the
human during which time the human is
fundamentally transformed once they've
been infected the
scp-3003-3 human becomes obsessed with
spreading the mars and develops a
pleasure response to being in its
presence they maintain their
intelligence and become hyper-rational
able to evaluate information quickly and
effectively without any influence of
emotions while the capacity for emotions
remains these humans rarely express them
and almost never act on them they have
one primary function to spread the
infection further it sounds like the
beginning of an alien invasion but the
invasion already happened the war is
over and the humans of the planet
orbiting hip-569
have lost the infection is not growing
it's already complete
scp-3003 has a population of 30 billion
humans and every single one is host to
scp-3003-1 parasites this happened
centuries ago and the entire society has
since been reshaped to accommodate these
parasitic creatures and to make the
human population more hospitable to them
while these humans are identical to
those on earth they lack its genetic
diversity the humans of scp-3003 have
been selectively bred to make ideal
hosts complete with larger bodies more
fat tissue higher pain tolerance and
less susceptibility to diseases but the
society has not degraded due to the
infection quite the opposite the
scp-3003-3 population has become a hive
mind of sorts working together towards a
single purpose as such these humans have
evolved to be far more united than
humans on earth they all speak a single
language similar to dutch with no other
languages still active all humans belong
to the same culture and research has
indicated this is about 500 years old
before the infection they were a humble
society that had over 7 000 different
cultures and mainly engaged in trading
none of them exist anymore and they
aren't the only thing that's gone
scp-3003 lacks earth's genetic diversity
in animal and plant life that's because
in the early wave of
scp-3003-1 infections the newly infected
humans targeted any species that preyed
on the mars these mass extinctions
created famines and other ecological
catastrophes and led to a massive change
in the way the humans of scp-3003
live the vast majority now live in
carefully planned cities built in the
safe and temperate regions of the planet
these cities are mostly enclosed and are
used for industry and food growth they
are also extremely tightly built so much
so that scp personnel reported feeling
claustrophobic many surfaces of the
cities are coated with the material that
closely resembles the feel of scp-3003-1
the mars beetle the infected are so
fixated on the pleasure that being
around these beetles gives them that
they use this as a form of entertainment
the remaining members of this society
live in rural areas in small carefully
planned communities dedicated to farming
mining or manufacturing these small pods
are even more structured than the cities
children in this world are raised
communally by large groups of workers
specializing in health and education
they are infected quickly at only a
little over a year old which is as soon
as their supervisors are convinced
they're physically capable once they are
infected and their mindsets converted to
the interests of the mars the children
are quickly tested to determine their
ideal occupation before being steered
into what they will do for the rest of
their life where like everything else on
scp-3003
their day-to-day life will be highly
structured adults typically spend 10
hours a day at work with the rest being
spent engaging in basic activities like
eating sleeping attending educational
classes and engaging in entertainment
but the entertainment all revolves
around the society's obsession with
scp-3003-1
they listen to recordings of the beetle
swarms visit the enclosures where the
beetles are bred or obsessively touch
the distinctive lumps that the parasite
cause on their hosts everyone fits in on
scp-3003
there is no other option any sign of
divergence from one's job function is
cause for the authorities to step in the
first step is medical exams to make sure
that the parasitic infestation isn't
becoming too harmful anyone who doesn't
conform to the social standards is
restrained by local members of the hive
mind and brought in for observation when
someone becomes too old or sick to work
for society and act as a host for the
mars their usefulness is at an end and
they are used for organ harvesting and
experimentation in the society of
scp-3003 one life has no meaning its
only worth is the value it can bring to
the hive mind there's one area of
scp-3003's development that is of
greater concern to the foundation though
their technology
scp-3003-3 works as one and that has
allowed it to develop technology far
beyond that of what we have on earth
their planet is run almost entirely on
wind solar and tidal power with a small
amount also coming from geothermal and
nuclear their computers have enough
power to produce data that makes
foolproof recommendations for public
policy and their artificial intelligence
systems are far beyond anything the
foundation has developed their crops
have been genetically modified to have
ideal heartiness and nutritional value
and they routinely experiment on their
own dna for selective breeding purposes
the planet has launched satellites into
space and visited the other planets in
their solar system but it's one
invention in particular that has brought
this strange planet to the foundation's
attention
scp-3003
is a massive facility on
scp-3003 with one purpose to open
wormholes that can transport members of
the planet to any other point in space
each use of this device uses up more
energy than earth uses in a full year
and the device seems to have been
created with one goal in mind to
transport representatives to other
planets that can expand their parasitic
civilization to the desire to spread the
infection of the mars is a single-minded
obsession for the citizens of scp-3003
and they now have their sights set on
earth unlike most dangerous specimens
scp-3003 and its native species were not
discovered in the wild rather it made
contact directly with the earth through
its wormhole generator sending
ambassadors who came bearing the news of
their gospel of a better unified way of
life that would be achieved by joining
their growing empire they could have
passed for missionaries but what they
were preaching was infection with a
parasitic mutated beetle the scp
foundation was not prepared for this
first contact and collected all the
evidence they could on this strange new
society they quickly came up with one
conclusion
scp-3003 was larger more powerful and
more advanced than anything on earth
even the scp foundation with no other
option available for containing the
threat the foundation took the only
approach they could making peaceful
contact with the ambassadors and making
them think earth was interested in what
they were offering as long as the
representatives of scp-3003
think they are involved in peaceful
negotiations for how to introduce the
mars to earth they are ready to
cooperate and agree to some of the
foundation's terms this has given the
foundation the opportunity to study the
society and identify some potentially
exploitable weak points and they've
found one in particular that may give
humans a chance for survival that
weakness the representatives of
scp-3003-3
do not know how to lie once they're
converted to host the mars everything
they do serves a common purpose and is
shared with every other member of their
hive-like society there is no need to
lie and no purpose to it in their
society and as such they can be deceived
far more easily than most humans that
gives the scp foundation the chance to
stall them and fool them into thinking
earth is planning for integration at its
own pace but even the residents of this
strange civilization's patience may have
its limits the representatives seem
cooperative at first agreeing to many
concessions the foundation requested
including carefully regulating where
they entered earth and making the
foundation their first point of contact
for their earth contact and research
committee this allows the foundation to
ensure no invasive species makes their
entry onto earth unknown because the
civilization is unable to lie the
foundation has convinced them that earth
is contaminated and unable to host the
mars with the species becoming sterile
when introduced the representatives seem
to believe this and believe they are
working on a solution with earth but
some members of
scp-3003-3 may be becoming more
aggressive it was after a meeting with a
representative of scp-3003 that
foundation researcher dr shaw entered an
elevator with the alien suddenly the
marst host became enraged tearing the
control panel out of the wall and
stopping the elevator dr shaw was
terrified but the representative simply
said it wanted some alone time
the
scp-3003-3 representative started
speaking but it didn't seem to speak
like the other members it was intense
and intimidating and most worrying it
referred to taking over a two-legged
species over 500 years ago it wasn't the
human speaking but neither was it the
mars no this was the single cell
organism that had puppeteered both them
and the mars unlike the humans of
scp-3003
it wasn't fooled by the foundation's
subterfuge it knew they were resisting
and it didn't believe the story about
the planet being inhospitable to the
mars it wanted the earth to surrender
and join the hive mind and it argued
earth would be better for it no more war
no more conflict no more hate no more
poverty all it would take was the
complete surrender of everyone on
earth's free will and it made clear that
it would win it would be the last thing
the only thing left in the universe and
everyone would join it one way or
another it was clear that the threat of
scp-3003 was more pressing than thought
which posed a question how do you
contain an entire planet the decision to
classify scp-3003 as ketter wasn't hard
but none of the foundation's other
tactics they'd used in the past would
apply here investigation into the
capabilities of the planet made clear
that if a war was to break out between
the two planets it would end swiftly and
decisively in favor of scp-3003
if the
scp-3003-2 living inside the bloodstream
of the planet's humans were aware of the
foundation's deceptions they did not
seem to be letting the humans of their
planet in on this so the deception would
hold for now but scp-3003 was moving
fast as well and soon it might be too
late to contain it two projects in
particular concern the foundation one is
a genetic tampering experiment to make
scp-3003-3 more hospitable to their
purpose it would add artificial genes to
their human hosts making them consume
less resources becoming immune to common
pathogens and making them able to host
10 times as many mars inside their
bodies these genes would turn the
infected humans into their own new
species they are working on traveling to
and terraforming planets in other star
systems which would make them capable of
spreading virtually anywhere and at that
point impossible to contain but the
foundation has some last-ditch plans in
motion to stop this in addition to
continuing their disinformation campaign
and the ongoing research into samples of
the mars and the single cell being that
mutates them the foundation is preparing
for the worst case scenario too
they are spreading disinformation among
scientists to ensure no additional
contact is made with elements outside
the scp foundation and the o5 council
has authorized studies into how to
eliminate this threat permanently but
the foundation will only have one chance
to do so and any attempt will need to
involve the elimination of their
wormhole device to keep them from
escaping because even one specimen
escaping could mean infestation of
another world and eventually the threat
would begin anew but for now the
foundation has not deemed any plans for
an attack to neutralize scp-3003 either
practical or likely to succeed which
means the foundation is left focusing on
maintaining stable relations with
scp-3003-a
they continue to try and convince them
that the earth is moving towards
peaceful integration and let's hope they
succeed in this task for as long as they
can because for now this is the only
thing we have standing between us and
the end of history for more on
terrifying insects check out
scp-3004 insect god or for another
world-ending event the foundation has
under wraps check out
scp-2317 the devourer of worlds